[Music]
Jared we were just taking bets here on
your favorite quarterback growing up you
want to settle the bet for us
sure okay I think I heard the end of it
okay you know I do love Joe Montana but
it was probably Aaron Rodgers oh man
okay I thought you took 16 because of
dill Montana
I did but I rather okay have you talked
to Rodgers yeah yeah
the Cal connection yeah yeah I saw him
this summer actually for the first time
and was able to spend all the time with
him just we were throwing on the same
field just once not only it was good it
was good to meet him all he said like
[Music]
can you learn anything from watching
these quarterbacks you know watching
Brady and Matt Ryan watching the
playoffs can you learn anything that you
could put into play yourself sure I
think you're always kind of trying to do
that I think no matter you know who you
are or what you're watching with
especially in the playoffs I mean these
guys are incredible last night watching
Rodgers was was something to behold and
I think Shawn with other quarterback
he's big fan you guys and I was texting
back and forth on like you don't think
people that don't play quarterback fully
appreciate what Rodgers was doing last
night it was it was unbelievable but
what are we not seeing though Jared to
be fair to what Rodgers is doing as a
quarterback watching an area quarterback
the would the way the way that he throws
it without his feet being said I'm
unbelievable like it's almost as if he
would rather not have his feet that way
he almost it's like degree of difficulty
when he's out of the pocket that's what
he's far more dangerous then you know
you a lot of these guys want to be in
the pocket Rodgers doesn't want to be he
goes out and why is he so effective when
he's out out of the pocket
it's it it's amazing I think a question
I can't body control and his ability to
throw a run is unbelievable and it just
it's it's it's incredible to watch
really and we'll watch it on film
I mean I've watched you know games it is
just on film and don't find yourself you
supposed to be watching the defense or
not you'll find yourself you know
templates are no crap I just walked
errands just do this thing those of the
defense can you do that can you teach
that teacher he does yeah I don't think
no no I don't think so do you think your
new head coach would be okay if if all
of a sudden you start saying hey Rodgers
does this I yeah I'm not gonna set my
feet coach Rogers does it I'm gonna just
wing it okay how you think that would go
over with there's some things take from
his game as well as many others but you
know what he does right now is kind of
unprecedented
he's Jared Goff the Rams quarterback
joining us have you met coach of course
yeah yeah I met him actually got some
time spent time catching and spent some
time with them a week ago for his
interview and it was really good as
positive them and talked some things out
and and then when he was hired I was
excited it was it was God I really
connected with and was really excited
for hire
we get caught up in his age what do you
think of what's the advantage of having
a 30 year old head coach Jerry looking
for us there's an advantage to it
because we are so young and there's that
you know his ability to connect with us
may be greater than an older coach I
think his ability to communicate may be
greater than an older coach but I think
it's you know they say age is just the
numbers you know but it really is when
it comes to you know just knowledge and
how smart he is and how sharp he is if
you if you really didn't know how it
wasn't you talk to you wouldn't know
these 30 years old and I think
himself like a like an older coach and I
got it you're leaking lyrical volume
what did you learn this year yeah I
learned a lot just from from not playing
and playing and you know being able to
watch case and dealing where case and
Shawn just everything in between I think
I'm very thankful for the experience of
actually not playing and being able to
watch from the side laughter a little
bit and being able to learn some things
that I probably wouldn't have learned
otherwise but you know it wasn't that's
a you know the most fun thing to watch
on the sideline foot I tried to I tried
to really get the most out of it and
enjoy it and when I got in there I got
my chance to play we often hear the
speed of the game it's one thing to
watch from the sidelines you make that
30 yard walk and you're in the middle of
a huddle there how different is it from
watching on the sidelines to actually be
in in combat there yeah anytime you play
it's gonna be a lot of different but I
think it becomes the same sport he
played since you were 8 years old for my
sauce about seven and it's it really
dispersed to slow down I started feeling
it probably some new ones game my second
game I started to kind of get that okay
this is kind of like college you came
feeling and it was it was really really
good and started to slow down I don't
feel the feels as well and see see guys
open can you say something mean about
the Chargers so we can maybe stoke up
this rivalry a little bit think I can I
think when we get or when I get drafted
to LA I kind of always understood that
you know probably second team was gonna
come and it was either probably be them
on the Raiders we kind of always need
that one surprise and when they were
saying they were gonna relocate but it's
gonna be fine I think it's somewhere in
New York's the big city New York set two
teams they make it work just fine I
think we can do the same thing
are you a Hollywood guy no I don't think
so
I don't think I want to be
yes I want to be a good football player
first so you just say you don't want to
have a reality show you don't want to be
you know the Kardashians of the although
you guys got hard knocks though no yeah
no I don't I don't I don't wish to be on
another hard knock sir did you see
Mannion had at one of our t-shirts on
during a hard knocks a flinch ball
t-shirt there he was like alright you
need to go in so your height and weight
right away
alright what's your height and weight
six-four two-twenty do you want to
flinch ball shirt Jared I'll send you
one I would love one
yeah I love one yeah I love when I wear
it and Sean probably I'm pretty mad
that's okay I can see another
quarterback behind his back no but you
know what's weird is we were openly
rooting for Mannion to get playing time
just because and I wasn't rooting for
your case to get hurt I just thought
manion's of fan of the show and be
better for the show if he actually got
some playing time there so just so you
know if word gets back to you that we
were rooting for Mannion it's only
because a nothing personal though Jerry
all right
well we'll send out a couple of we'll
send out a couple of t-shirts there
we'll send you a care package there
thank you thank you thank you hey
congrats on surviving the first year I
know that it's not as easy as some of
these guys make it look but good luck
with the new head coach and hopefully
good things better things down the road
for you thank you very much appreciate
you guys all right it's a Jared Goff you
got a new fan of the show all it takes
is a couple of t-shirts there the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]